all right the countdown is on to the
opening of las vegas's newest casino
good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here at 4 30. i'm christian
cosadas i'm kirsten joyce
resorts world will open to the public
tomorrow evening
joe moeller got a look inside today he
is live with a preview for us hey joe
hey there guys what an exciting time for
las vegas uh this is the first resort to
open on the las vegas strip
uh being built from the ground up in
more than a decade now take a look
behind us here
here at resorts world they want to make
sure this is a unique experience i mean
just look at all the monitors on the
outside it's unlike anything we else
we really see here on the strip now we
went inside earlier today we got a peek
at
the nine pools with bars and restaurants
the international
food options in a number of areas
throughout the resort
and the three hotel lobbies that each
made a statement of their own
now the more than four billion dollar
property is bringing a unique gambling
experience to the strip as well we spoke
to rick
hudson the resorts were the resorts
world vp of casino
he says guests can now transfer money
virtually to a resorts world app
pick an amount to bet and share a qr
code
i then show that qr code to our dealer
mark
and he'll scan it and it'll
automatically log me in
to this seat debits my cashless wagering
account
he gives me chips
when it comes to food there are plenty
of options with dozens of eateries
restaurants from around the country
and the world have opened up shop in the
famous foods area
of the resort which is more of a food
hall along the casino
another area called the district is
where you can find more sit down options
and retail now back out here live you're
taking another look
outside of resorts worlds here you can
see some of those crews are still out
there trying to put those finishing
touches on the outside
on those giant monitors that are out
there now the resorts grand opening
ribbon cutting ceremony is happening
tomorrow at 6 30 outside here
and it will open to the public tomorrow
at 11 p.m i'll send it back to you
joe those restaurants look to die for
how exciting is going to be great for
tourists and locals alike you mentioned
finishing touches
as we go past there looks like you know
as you mentioned some work still being
done is everything going to be completed
on time
well i want to give you another look out
here there's plenty of crews out here
you can see some
big bulldozers or different uh tractors
and things out here
crews working on the screens everything
is basically finished
with resorts world they're still the the
day club and nightclub have to be
finished the theater needs to be
finished as well but
at the casino the restaurants most of
the restaurants that is the eateries
are all set to be uh done and complete
for tomorrow night i'll send it back to
you
thanks very much joe mola reporting live
on the las vegas strip christian